we have talked about soda bans for a
long time on the program New York City
is one of the bigger places most notable
places where Michael Bloomberg pushed
for these bans on really big sodas being
sold at convenience stores Chicago a
couple of months ago also passed a soda
ban they're already repealing it it's
been two months in Chicago is going to
be repealing their soda ban the Cook
County Chicago is in Cook County the
Board of Commissioners in Cook County
voted 15 to 1 to roll backs back the
soda tax not a ban and they're gonna
make it effective as soon as December 1
big soda has spent a ton of money trying
to make this happen
ad buys lobbyists political
contributions and there's two very
interesting sides to the soda ban thing
one side is hey listen you tax soda or
you ban huge sodas it helps to fight
obesity it raises revenue for local
jurisdictions through those taxes and by
charging more and limiting soda sizes
you make it just more difficult and more
expensive for people to have as much
soda so you're gonna reduce calorie
consumption from soda it'll be good for
health overall okay that's the idea from
the advocates of the soda taxes or soda
bans now the counterpoint and these are
talking points that are very well liked
by the soda industry the counter point
is now you put a tax on these sodas you
hurt poorer people by making them have
to pay more for soda rich people are not
going to be affected by paying a little
bit more for soda and also richer people
drink a lot less soda than poorer people
so you're gonna disproportionately hurt
poorer people with these soda taxes it
hurts the owners of small businesses
like the corner stores that make some
significant share of their money from
soda sales and distributors are just
going to pass on the costs to consumers
so you're really only going to impact
the consumers now I don't drink soda I
haven't had any soda with the exception
of a rare coke when I travel and I can
get overseas the coke with
rather than the corn syrup coke I've
probably had I don't know five sodas in
the last ten years I think it is almost
poison and terrible for your health and
I don't advise the drinking of any soda
but that is separate from the economic
question of whether syntaxes of ice
taxes as they're sometimes called work
the idea of taxing cigarettes or soda so
what's the truth about that what appears
to be the case is that these types of
taxes do dissuade consumption if they
are high enough like really high but the
problem that you start to see when you
have really high syntaxes it that is
that it can incentivize the creation of
a black market now with cigarettes we
know that exists right untaxed
cigarettes that are brought from low
cigarette tax states to high cigarette
tax states so from certain states in the
south up to New York City creates a
black market for these types of products
it's more difficult to imagine a serious
soda black market but another issue is
that these types of taxes can make
government dependent on the behavior
let's think about it this way if you're
a government and you start taxing a
particular sin like cigarettes or or
soda for example the government comes to
expect that tax revenue and probably
become reliant on that tax revenue so
then you have a situation where
supposedly the reason for the syntax is
to dissuade usage or consumption of a
certain sin or vice but you actually as
a government are now dependent on the
money and it creates contradictory
incentives the tax is supposedly to
dissuade consumption but you earn more
revenue the more consumption there is so
what's an alternative one possibility
that I read about and this is really
interesting article in The Washington
Post last year about it tax sugar
instead of soda what am I talking about
well instead of focusing on the volume
of a soda
is it a 64 ounce soda or a 32 or 16
ounce soda and taxing that look at the
sugar content look at a tax on high
sugar drinks
you can Institute attacks based on sugar
/ liquid volume okay and from the
Washington Post article when normalized
by the amount of taxes paid a one tier
tax which taxes only beverages that
cross a certain sugar threshold that
reduces sugar consumption by 25 percent
a straight volume tax based on the size
of the soda or the drink reduces sugar
intake by only 22 percent now it's not a
drastic difference 25% reduction versus
22 percent reduction but at scale that
could actually be a pretty significant
difference now you can already probably
predict one of the problems with taxing
grams of sugar you can keep the grams of
sugar down by using artificial
sweeteners I'm not particularly thrilled
with encouraging the use of artificial
sweeteners and masks because a large
number of those have their own share of
of health concerns so some people will
hear this story they'll so David you're
digging into the weeds the government
just has no business period getting
involved in something like this it is
just nanny state stuff I disagree
obesity is such a major public health
issue that we all pay for it you me and
the government through Medicare and
Medicaid so I think that it is perfectly
reasonable for state and local
governments and federal government to
have some kind of say to say ignore it
completely is completely crazy but send
me your thoughts what ideas do you have
for dealing with this in a way that
might not have the problems of the sugar
taxes I'm sorry of the soda taxes and
bans that we've seen send me your
thoughts